my name is lakeya I work for a pair
agency called the baton hook we've so
much you know social media channels out
there and apps on platforms how does a
brand choose which one is the most
relevant social media app to use to
reach their customer you know I think a
brand needs to be smart enough to know
who their customer is oh by the way what
I've come to learn is most of them don't
because they pay Boehner McKinsey or
Cambridge group or Boston Consulting a
shitload of money for a small sample
size of data and they decided we're
targeting this female meanwhile you see
the chatter and conversation public free
data showing you that your brand is not
necessarily just to these people look at
all these people I'll never forget saks
fifth avenue i had an early meeting with
them back in 09 and they didn't even
want it was that Cristal thing they
didn't want the customers that were
talking I'm like but third customers
like it's an insane thing to decide
which customers you want right I get
owning the brand but that becomes you
know you can be put in a very tough spot
if you don't realize it you know to me
it's it's getting the best day that you
have from your retail partners if you're
a brand to figure out who's actually
buying your product and then mapping it
to where those people actually are and
that date is tough to come by but I
think some of its anecdotal from a
strategy standpoint I don't think 50 to
70 year old men are on snapchat if they
are they're probably doing some
gangster-ass [ __ ] right
but it so so I i think it's i also think
i want to say this I also think there
needs to be a purpose while you jump on
something we put brands on early
platforms we put General Electric on
buying the first day because the
strategy has earned media by GE getting
earned media of being a first mover in
that platform within the trade they're
attracting better talent so it depends
on what your KPIs you know there's a lot
of kick at the highest levels at the CEO
level at the real [ __ ] that matters
level there's more things than just
selling the product on the shelf right
there's the stock price there's
recruiting talent there's biz dev
there's affect how about when a CPG
brand jumps on snapchat gets a lot of
press and all of a sudden Tesco and
walmart want to do business with them
because they think they're innovative so
like if I put you on snapchat and it
gets you a ton of press and that helps
you get a better relationship with your
biggest customer wasn't that a good
reason to do it everybody is just too
black and white the world is gray yeah